buon pomeriggio
vi chiedo gentilmente per un attimo di
chiudere gli occhi ed immaginare che
questo evento di ted ha ben kata
trent'anni in una terra non più popolata
da uomini va da esseri con intelligenza
artificiale al mio posto c'è uno di
questi esseri con intelligenza
artificiale che inizia la storia e dice
c'era una volta l'uomo questo uomo aveva
due braccia due gambe una testa e un
cervello
e un rappresentante del pubblico si alza
e chiede ma allora qual è la differenza
anche noi ci abbiamo due braccia abbiamo
due gambe abbiamo un cervello
perché loro erano diversi perché l'uomo
era diverso
e la risposta è
l'uomo aveva creatività
aveva passione sapeva analizzare i
sentimenti
l'uomo aveva un intelligenza emozionale
adesso riaprite i vostri occhi se li
avete mai chiusi e ritornate qui sono io
adesso che parlo kharlan
e la storia continua in brasile quando
sono stata nominata
amministratore delegato della presente
le cong la pre tir télécom a quell'epoca
era un'azienda che passa era un momento
di transizione
la società statale era stata
privatizzata e si stava
inventando doveva diventare una società
di mercato verso protesa verso il
mercato
dei quattro operatori che all'epoca
c'erano in brasile di rete fissa la
brasil telecom era considerata il brutto
anatroccolo
era un un operatore regionale nonostante
si coprisse un'area che andava da
brasilia fino a rio grande do sul quindi
dal nord fino proprio al sud ma era
interna in quelle che erano considerato
all'epoca le regioni meno nobili del
brasile sicuramente non avevamo nella
nostra area rio san paolo salvadori di
baia
tutti nomi che certamente voi conoscete
se non altro per il carnevale
era piccola piccola in termini di
revenue in termini di servizi era
appunto il brutto anatroccolo e aveva 11
mila persone
il primo giorno che sono entrata nella
brasil telecom la sede principale la
sensazione che ho avuto è stata una
sensazione che si può descrivere con una
parola grigio tutto era grigio le pareti
erano grigie
le persone erano grigie non c'era
entusiasmo non c'era niente che facesse
percepire che questa era un'azienda che
aveva dei risultati da raggiungere
naturalmente è iniziato solito processo
per me di sedermi tutti i giorni con
l'alta direzione capire fare piani come
aumentare le revenue diminuire costi
le nuove tecnologie da
apportare ma tutte le sere quanto io
tornavo nella mia stanza d'albergo
all'epoca non avevo ancora all'inizio
non avevo ancora un appartamento io mi
chiedevo ma come farò come faremo a
realizzare i piani che stiamo pensando
che dovremmo fare sulla carta se non
riuscirò a superare the wall perché in
quel momento ero circondata da wall e
qual era la vuole la vuole era come
sarei riuscita a comunicare
con tutto il personale della brasil
telecom e fare in modo che prendessero i
progetti che l'alta direzione stava
pensando che sulla carta vi assicuro
erano perfetti perché ricordate di tutti
i piani sono perfetti tutte le
proiezioni sono sempre perfette fino al
momento che devi realizzarle e quindi
qual è l'elemento
di differenza perché è un'idea si
realizza è un'altra non si realizza sono
le persone e io avevo bisogno di 11 mila
persone
il problema per me non era il fatto che
era una donna o che ero una straniera
che stava gestendo una società
brasiliana come italiana il mio problema
era che dovevo comunicare con queste 11
mila persone dovevo fare in modo che
pensassero e che acquisiscono questo
progetto come loro
in quel periodo stavo mi stavo anche
allenando per la mia prima maratona
avevo fatto tutto il percorso che si fa
di solito noi 10 km
poi la mezza maratona è finita maratona
e una mattina mentre mi stavo allenando
e per l'ennesima volta mi stavo
chiedendo perché carla è deciso di fare
una maratona poteva imparare a giocare a
scacchi che non ha mai voluto imparare
te ne stavi a casa
in tutto questo e mi ripetevo tutte le
motivazioni perché uno si fanno a
maratona perché è un obiettivo
autodisciplina
st minya e tutti i valori che sono
collegati con fare una maratona avere un
obiettivo
davanti mi sono resa conto che questi
potevano diventare gli obiettivi
per il personale della brasil telecom
per iniziare con me questa lunghissima
maratona
che era all'inizio e così ho fatto
arriva in azienda
espongo questo mio piano e vi dico che
devo dire che non so ancora oggi dopo
tanti anni non so se gli altri
componenti del comitato esecutivo
mi guardo in centro mi ha guardato un po
come se fossi un po
una visionaria no cercando il perché
cercavo di spiegare che volevo usare la
corsa errani una mia passione
e i valori legati a questo per
coinvolgere 11.000 dipendenti da brasil
telecom comunque il direttore del
personale
cioè io la persona che può essere adatta
per te e quindi mi presenta questa
giovane donna vandelli alla quale spiego
il mio progetto cioè usare lo sport
specificatamente la corsa e i valori
legati allo sport come motivazione per
motivare l'azienda e soprattutto per
essere il primo passo per cambiare la
cultura e da una cultura e per
raggiungere gli obiettivi
creiamo un piccolo gruppo che risponde
direttamente a me perché ricordatevi che
in qualsiasi organizzazione un
cambiamento culturale non può avvenire
se chi è al comando
non è direttamente responsabile
chi è al comando deve essere la persona
responsabile perché cambiare
culturalmente un'azienda è una
organizzazione non sto parlando
solamente di corporation posso essere
organizzazioni statali può essere spesso
la stessa politica se non c'è un impegno
giornaliero tutti i giorni direttamente
da chi l'ha pensato non avviene
siete destinati al fallimento
dopo due anni quindi iniziamo questo
processo dove veramente costituiamo
gruppi di corsa cioè non è stata una
metafora noi mettiamo in tutte le saab
sider della brasil telecom da tutte le
parti costruiamo dei gruppi di corsa
prendiamo dei personal trainer in
maniera mali che insegnino iniziamo a
diffondere i valori e viene tutto un
programma motivazionale il cui risultato
è che dopo due anni il brutto
anatroccolo è diventato lunar cigno
bianco dopo due anni a brasil telecom è
stata nominata la miglior società di
telecomunicazioni
del sud america quindi non solo del
brasile del sudamerica
come potuto avvenire questo continuava
mo a operare nello stesso al territorio
quindi avevamo gli stessi potenziali
clienti
avevamo la stessa competizione che in
realtà prima era davanti
e avevamo a disposizione le stessi
servizi e tecnologie della competizione
non è che noi in quel momento stavamo
offrendo qualcosa di diverso
quindi cosa è stata la differenza
l'ho detto allora e lo ripeto c'è la
differenza è stata il fatto che
11mila persone che poi nel tempo erano
diminuite ma comunque il corpo il
dipendenti della brasil telecom hanno
fatto loro
la corsa
hanno capito
che il successo dell'azienda dipendeva
da loro hanno capito che qualsiasi
successo dell'azienda si sarebbe
riflesso sopra di loro e l'hanno preso
come proprio questa è l'unica
spiegazione che io per il fatto che in
due anni la brasil tese kong hsi così
trasformata non era più un operatore
nazionale siamo diventati un operatore
scusate un'ape trattore regionale siamo
diventati un operatore nazionale
avevamo iniziato un processo di
cambiamento di cultura e questo era
dovuto semplicemente al fattore umano
non era niente legato alla tecnologia
non era legato a nessun tipo di speciale
innovazione solamente l'innovazione
nelle risorse umane e naturalmente
abbiamo avuto anche dei bene degli
effetti collaterali positivissimi ci
siamo già con la società è stata lì
stata alla borsa di new york questo
gruppo piccolo gruppo molti
motivazionale e di corsa che era nato
per uno scopo specifico ha iniziato ad
avere una vita
indipendente all'interno dell'azienda
sempre sotto la mia diretta supervisione
e abbiamo iniziato a creare altri
progetti sociali all'interno
dell'azienda
abbiamo pensiamo abbiamo creato progetti
sociali al fuori dell'azienda
abbiamo creato progetti sociali per i
bambini bisognosi per le strade creando
scuole di di triathlon per bambini per
tirare via questi ragazzini dalle strade
ricordatevi che siamo in brasile abbiamo
creato progetti per gli anziani
e siamo diventati il maggiore
patrocinatore di sport a livello
nazionale privato perché naturalmente
poi c'erano i ministeri pubblici ma come
azienda privata siamo stati i più
eravamo i più coinvolti
tanto che nelle olimpiadi del 2004 la
brasil telecom aveva presenti 28 atleti
tutti i patronati del brasil telecom tra
olimpiadi e paraolimpiadi
abbiamo vinto medaglie d'oro e medaglie
d'argento
ma al di là delle medaglie abbiamo
portiamo abbiamo creato da un'idea che è
nata per superare una parete beyond the
wall abbiamo creato un altro
meraviglioso progetto che ha permesso
altre persone al di là fuori
dell'azienda di realizzare il loro sogno
di andare ai giochi olimpici
quindi la vera differenza in un mondo
dove oggi tutti abbiamo contatto con le
stesse tecnologie con le stesse
informazioni nello stesso momento
uno si chiede perché alcune
organizzazioni falliscono e altri hanno
successo
la risposta è semplice le persone le
persone sono secondo me ancora oggi il
vero la vero fattore differenziatore
un'idea di per se stessa scusate non
vale niente ed è stato dimostrato
durante l'internet l'inter bubble
intendente più deboli di primo fine anni
quante aziende avevano delle bellissime
idee e poi sony non si sono realizzate
mentre alcune aziende si sono costituite
perché perché dietro non c'era il
fattore umano non c'erano persone in
grado di prendere questa idea di
svilupparla e di realizzarla
e ricordatevi un'idea non è
necessariamente innovazione un'idea
l'innovazione non è necessariamente
qualcosa di tecnologico a volte è
innovazione e avere un'idea e
svilupparla vero successo è
guardare qualcosa che c'hai tutti i
giorni sotto gli occhi da un punto di
vista diverso
e capire che questa cosa può essere
qualcosa di diverso in oggi prendiamo
come esempio sempre google facebook
amazon che al di là di tutto sono
aziende che ammiro tantissimo le sue
notizie però io credo che l'azienda per
me per lo meno che rappresenta meglio
come guardare il quotidiano può
diventare una cosa enorme e starbucks il
signor schulz è venuto in italia ha
guardato al ha guardato al bar italiano
no noi ce l'abbiamo tutti i giorni per
noi è normale andare al bar sedersi
prendere un caffè magari stare due ora
leggere il giornale gazzetta dello
sport.it o sul corriere della sera il
lunedì tipicamente lo faccio anche io
guardo al corriere della sera gazzetta
dello sport se ha vinto la mia squadra
se no no e lui l'ha presa l'ha portata
in stati uniti quindi niente di
innovativo cioè niente di tecnologico e
ha fatto un business
meraviglioso non solo è stato il primo
secondo me che ha creato il social
network perché il socio perché l'idea
come è stato venduto star ma non è stata
venduta come il bar per andare a
prendere il cappuccino no è stata
venduto come un punto di incontro che
come sappiamo poi nel 2008 è diventato
il punto di incontro di chi non aveva
lavoro che andava a per cercare lavoro
ma questo fa parte un'altra storia
quindi
il da un'idea non tecnologica è venuto
fuori una grandissima e l'avevamo lì
tutti i giorni sotto tutti i giorni
quindi il superare
superare il wall significa guardare
quello che tu hai davanti e cercare di
ri interpretarlo
però vi dico una cosa
se decidete di superare le vuole
innanzitutto pensate subito che dopo
questa wall ci sarà un'altra wall ma
dovete avere coraggio superare un awol
significa guardare out of the box
significa guardare qualcosa in maniera
così differente che sicuramente andrete
contro in molti casi ai paradigmi della
società
non è così semplice non aver coraggio
bisogna avere determinazione
sapere dove si vuole arrivare
e ricordarsi sempre che se volete questa
è la mia ricetta oggi se volete avere
successo se volete che la vostra
organizzazione sia differente dalle
altre
non importa quanta tecnologia portate e
ve lo dico io che ho lavorato sempre la
tecnologia
se non riuscite a fare in modo di
interpretare le risorse umane non avrete
successo
soprattutto oggi dove la tecnologia sta
portando a rivedere tutti i processi di
questo l'effetto altri tutti i processi
all'interno di un'azienda
ma dovete essere in grado di gestire le
risorse umane questo è la grande il
grande
la grande sfida che sia oggi davanti si
pensa che già perché siano le tecnologia
sia tutto assolutamente no e quindi io
credo e spero che tra cent'anni
quando ci sarà un ted ancora qui a
verona non ci saranno questi essere di
intelligenza artificiale
io sono sicura che ci sarà spero che ci
sarà ancora l'uomo con tutte le sue
debolezze ma sicuramente con questa
mente che non solo crea idee sviluppa le
tecnologie perché richiudiamo c che
dietro ogni tecnologia c'è stato
qualcuno o più di qualcuno che l'ha
pensata ma soprattutto è capace di
interpretare tutto quello che la
tecnologia da è inutile avere dati se
non si sanno interpretare i dati
e come finale se non so se siete
interessati a sapere la mia
la mia carriera di maratoneta
dopo la prima maratona ne ho fatte altre
e ogni volta cercavo di superare la
barriera dei 4 delle 4 ore naturalmente
vi confesso che ancora oggi non l'ho
fatta non sono riuscita quindi continua
imperterrita ma ho chiesto un giorno a
uno dei vari allenatori che poi cambiato
allenatore perché pensavo che fosse
sempre colpa loro invece di essere io
ovviamente e gli ho chiesto a uno ti
senti un altro di cui sono qualche passo
tutti i giorni mi alleno stand faccio
tutto quello che mi dite perchè non
riesco andare sotto le quattro ore e lui
mi guarda e mi dice carla deve rinascere
al grazie